اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله
واصحابه
اجمعين اما
بعد يقول
تعالى وان تعجب فعجب قولهم ائذا كنا ترابا
اانا لفي خلق
جديد اولئك الذين كفروا بربهم واولئك الا
اعنا واولئك اصحاب النار هم فيها
خالدون ستر سوره
الرعد
number
translation قوله تعالى وان
تعجب
هذا معطوف
على قوله تعالى في بدايه
السوره ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون فقوله تعالى والذي انزل اليك من
ربك الحق ولكن اكثر الناس لا يؤمنون وان
تعجب فعجب قولهم وان تعجب بهذا ان هذا
القران الذي هو كلام الله
منزل وهو اعظم الكتب منزل على اعظم الرسل
يتلوه على
ا يتلوه على العرب الذين عاش فيهم عمرا
وعرفوه وكان يعرف بالصادق
الامين
وامانهم ما زالت موضوعه
عنده ومع ذلك كله
وقد قال الله تعالى في هذا المعنى وكيف
تكفرون وانتم تتلى عليكم ايات الله وفيكم
رسوله
يعني ايات على
ايات فقال تعالى والذي انزل اليك من ربك
الحق ولكن اكثر الناس لا يؤمنون وان تعجب
فعجب قولهم هذا هو
التقدير وقيل
التقدير في
متعلق بما سبق من
الالتفات الى هذه الايات
الحسيه الله سبحانه وتعالى سخر الشمس
والقمر كل يجري لاجل مسمى ومد الارض وجعل
فيها رواسي
وانهارا ومن كل الثمرات جعل فيها زوجين
اثنين يغشي الليل النهار وفي الارض قطع
متجاورات وان تعجب ف عجب قوله يعني وان
تعجب من
هذه العجائب هي في الحقيقه
عجائب
وبالذات ما سلف ذكره في الايه السابقه وفي
الارض قطع متجاورات
وجنات من اعناب وزرع ونخيل صنوان وغير
صنوان يسقى بماء واحد ونفضل بعضها على بعض
في الاكل
فقال
تعالى وان تعجب فعجب قوله يعني ان عجبت من
هذا فاعجب
منه
انهم كيف يكفرون بقدره الله وهم يعلمون
هذا وقد سبق ان
ذكرنا
ان الكفار الذين بعث ان بعث الله نبينا
اليهم عليه الصلاه والسلام قوم يؤمنون
بوجود الله
يؤمنون
باكثر ربوبيه الله الربوبيه يعني ان الله
تعالى يخلق وانه يرزق وانه يدبر وانه
يؤمنون بهذا
كله
لكن في اعتقادهم انهم يعبدون غير الله
يعبدون هذه الالهه التي هي في الحقيقه
عباره عن صالحين
بزعمهم وهؤلاء يقربون الى الله زلفه وان
الله تعالى قد اودع في هذ
هذه في تلك الالهه او
تلك الاولياء بزعمهم اودع فيهم بعض القدره
على التصرف بشيء من ملك الله سبحانه
وتعالى وهذا اعتقاد قديم
مثل قول بعض المشركين
لنبيهم ان نقولوا الا اعتراك بعض الهتنا
بسوء
يعني ان بعض الهتنا انت تشتم
الهتنا فبعضهم اعتراك بسوء
هذا ليس يعني ان الله
تعالى لا يعبدونه بل يعبدونه ويرون انه
سبحانه وتعالى
واصل جميع الاشياء لكن يرون ان بعض هذه
الالهه قد اودع الله فيها شيء من هذه
القوه فقال تعالى وان تعجب فعجب
قولهم ائذا كنا ت اانا لفي خلق
جديد وهذا هو
البعث
فهم
يكفرون بلا اله الا الله ويكفرون
بالبعث يكفرون بلا اله الا الله اي يؤمنون
بان الله تعالى
واحد
ولكن يكفرون
بصرف العباده لله وحده دون ما سواه يقولون
نعبده ونعبد معه
غيره وكانوا يقولون هذا لله كما قال تعالى
هذا لله بزعمهم وهذا
لشركائنا فما كان لشركائهم فلا يصل الى
الله وما كان لله فهو يصل الى
شركائهم وقال تعالى حكايه عن هذا المعتقد
اجعل الالهه الها واحدا ان هذا لشيء
عجاب وكانوا يكفرون
بالبعث يقولون من يحيي العظام وهي
رميم يستبعدون هذا الشيء
لماذا سبحان الله الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول
ولو كان من عند غير الله لوجدوا فيه
اختلافا
كثي الانسان مهما كان فطنا مهما كان عاقلا
مهما كان حكيما فانه لا بد ان
يتناقض اذا كان من رايه رايه لا بد ان
يتناقض شيئا
ما
لابد لذلك حتى العلماء رحمهم
الله لم يسلموا من
التناقض الجزئي شيء من التناقض تقرا مثلا
من
في كتاب من كتب
العلماء
وتجده يقول براي وبعده بصفحات او بعده
بمجلدات يقول براي مخالف هذا شان
الانسان ولو كان من عند غير الله لوجدوا
فيه اختلاف كثيره وهؤلاء العلماء الذين
يمشون على نور من الله لذلك الله سبحانه
وتعالى لم يجعل العلم في
صدر رجل واحد ولا اثنين ولا عش ولا 20 ولا
100 ولا 200 العلماء
كثر حتى اذا اخطا
احدهم ردوه
اخوانه ورجعوه
وصوبه ف الانسان مهما كان ذكيا مهما كان
فطنا مهما كان من
امره ما كان فانه لا بد انه يكون عنده ايش
شيء من التناقض شيء من التناقض لابد فهذا
تناقض هم يؤمنون بان الله تعالى هو الذي
خلق اول مره لكن يستبعدون ان الله تعالى
يعيد الخلق
ويحيي العظام وهي رمي لذلك الله سبحانه
وتعالى
يستدل
عقلا
فيقول قل من انشاها اول مره الله سبحانه
وتعالى هو الذي انشا هذه الاشياء من
العدم
فاعاد من باب الا من باب اولى اعاده هذه
الاشياء من باب اولى ولذلك يقول وهو اهون
عليه ليس معناه ان شيء يصعب وانما
هذا يعني بمعنى
تنازلا مع
الخصم لو قلنا فرضا بكذا فعلى حسب قواعد
المفروض الامور تكون
هكذا
يقول اولئك الذين كفروا بربهم كفروا
بربهم فهم يؤمنون بوجود الله صح
لكن استبعدوا بعض قدره الله فهذا هو الكفر
فقال تعالى اولئك الذين كفروا
بربهم وهذه مساله مهمه لان الايمان يطلق
في القران يطلق في السنه ويراد به
جرعا من اجتمع المؤمن من اجتمعت فيه صفات
معينه واذا تخلفت صفه من هذه الصفات فانه
ينفى
عنه الكمال او ينفى عنه
الكل
فمثلا انسان يؤمن بجميع الرسل الا رسولا
واحدا يكفر به نقول هذا انا استبعد لكن
الباقي انا اؤمن
به باقين انا اؤمن بهم ماذا يكون من امره
هذا هو الكفر تماما الله سبحانه وتعالى
يقول ويريدون ان يفرقوا بين بين الله
ورسله ويقولون نؤمن ببعض ونكفر ببعض
ويريدون ان يتخذ بين ذلك سبيلا اولئك هم
الكافرون
حقا هذا هو الكفر والله عز وجل نص على ان
هذا هو الكفر
اولئك هم الكافرون حقا فحصر الكفر فيهم
لماذا مع انهم اهون من غيرهم ممكن بانهم
يؤمنون بشيء من الجواب حتى لا يتبادر الى
الذهن ان الانسان اذا امن بكل هذه بجميع
الرسل وكفر بواحد يعني
واحد ان هذا اقل سوءا ممن كفر بجمله من
الرسل الجواب لا من كفر برسول كفر بالرسل
اجمعين ومن كفر بكتاب كفر بجميع
الكتب وكذلك من كفر بركن من اركان الايمان
كفر
بها ومن اشرك مع الله غيره فانه ليس بمؤمن
شرعا هذا هو تماما
الكفر فيقول سبحانه وتعالى ا
الذين كفروا بربهم واولئك الاغلال في
اعناقهم الاغلال المعنويه في الدنيا فهم
لا يستطيعون ان ينظروا ويبصر الحق ومن لم
يجعل الله له نورا فما له من نور وكذلك
الاغلال في اعناقهم يوم القيامه
حسا واولئك اصحاب
النار هم فيها
خالدون كلمه
صاحب اصحاب النار هم
الذين
يلازمون دار البوار يلازمون جهنم والعياذ
بالله ابد
الابدين فالله سبحانه
وتعالى اذا
قال اصحاب النار اهل النار ما شابه
ذلك فهذا يدل على انه كفر لانه لا يكون
هذا الا للكافر في
القران لا يطلق على المؤمن الذي يستحق
شيئا من العقوبه بانه صاحب للنار او بانه
اهل للنار هذا ليس اهلا للنار ولا من
اصحاب النار في كتاب الله بل اذا رايت في
القران الجزاء بان فلانا يكون من اصحاب
النار فهذا يدل على ان هذا
ليس في عداد
الموحدين يقول تعالى هم فيها خالدون
ويستعجلونك بالسيئه قبل الحسنه يعني يوم
القيامه
يقولون
فل تاتي بعذاب من عند الله اذا كنت صادقا
او اذا كنت صادقا فل يقم
ربك ا القيامه
الان فهم يستعجلون بالسيئه قبل الحسنه
وكان المفروض ان
يقول ان كنت صادقا فادع ربك ان
يهدينا هذه هي
الحسنه ان كنت صادقا ان كنت نبيا صدقا
وحقا فادعو ربك ان يفتح قلوبنا
للايمان ان يسلك النور في قلوبنا ان
يجعلنا نبصر ما تقول ونفهم
ان يجعل لنا بصيره نعرف
الحق بانه حق ونرزق اتباعه هذا هذه الحسنه
لكن هم لا يقولون ذلك فهذا يدل على
انهم ليس يرفضون الرساله هم
يرفضون او نقول ليس هم
يرفضون ليسوا
براف
ل ما جاء به الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم ليسوا رافضين للرسول رافضين
للرساله
لا يؤمن احدهم مهما
جاءهم لانه خلص هو
ليس لم يبني هذا الذي كفر لم يبني كفره
على الادله او عدم وجود ادله هو بنى كفره
على ماذا على
الهوى كما
قال قوم فرعون
لموسى وقالوا مهما تاتنا به من ايه
لتسحرنا بها فما نحن لك بمؤمن فش
مستحيل نؤمن قبل ما تجيهم الايات
كفروا فكل ما جاءت ايه زادتهم
كفرا فهؤلاء
كثره الايات او قله الايات لا تنفعهم
لماذا لانهم لم يبنوا كفرهم على الاست
دلال بنوه على
الهوى فمهما جاءهم
فانهم
يدفعهم هواهم للكفر به قال ويستعجلونك
بالسيئه قبل الحسنه وقد خلت من قبلهم
المثولات
هذه ليست
جديده بل اخوانهم من الكفار من
قبلهم
المنك
المنكرون للرسل
والرسالات فهذا ديدنهم وهذا
شانهم وقد خلت من قبلهم المثلات من
الاهلاك
والتدمير عندما يكفرون ويستعجلون بالسيئه
قبل الحسنه يقول تعالى وان ربك لذو مغفره
للناس على ظلمهم لسائل ان يسال اذا قد خلت
من قبلهم المثولات لما لم
يدمرهم ربنا سبحانه وتعالى اذا كانت
هذه حقيقتهم ولا يؤمنون ولو جاءتهم كل ايه
حتى يروا العذاب الاليم
فلماذا يمدهم
لماذا يتركهم سبحانه وتعالى
يكفرون فالله سبحانه
وتعالى لذو مغفره للناس على
ظلمهم هذا من حلم الله وان الله تعالى لا
يعاجل
بالعقوبه بل قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان الله ليملي للظالم حتى اذا اخذه لم
يفلته وان ربك لشديد العقاب
اي
اهل الكرم اهل الايمان اهل
الشكر هم يرون ان
تاجيل العقوبه من كرم الله ومن عفو الله
ليس مما
يستحقونه فيشكر الله ويزدادون شكرا
وايمانا واما الكافر واما
الفاجر فانه يرى هذا الاحسان من الله ويت
ذه كالضعف
يراه كان الله تعالى يحبه الله لم يعاجل
بالعقوبه
اذا الله سبحانه يرضى ما عليه هذا الفاجر
من
فجوره
ولذلك تاتي هذه الاقوال مثل اقوال قارون
ماذا قال قال انما اوتيت على علم عندي انا
مستحق لهذه
لماذا يرى ان الله سبحانه وتعالى اعطاه
ولم يعطي غيره فاستدل به
على سبب انه الله اعطاني وما اعطى غيري
لاني انا بستحق انا اوتيت و على علم عندي
انا انسان قريب لله وكذلك
يستدل
يستدل الكافر او
الهالك افعال الله على اقوال الله ايش
يعني هذا
الكلام يعني
ينظر الى افعال
الله ويستدل بها على اقوال الله تاتي واحد
وتقول له ليش ما تصلي ققول لك لو شاء الله
ان اصلي
بيهديني صح ولا لا هذا هلاك لان الله امرك
بالصلاه فانت ما يحق لك تستدل بافعال الله
انه ما هداك على زعمك هذا فعل تستدل به
على اقوال الله هذا هو
تماما سبيل
الهالكين
تماما كذلك مثلا
ا هؤلاء ينظرون
الى ما اتاهم الله في الدنيا فيستدل
بها على الانبياء
والرسل فمثلا هذا الذي دخل جنته وهو ظالم
لنفسه قال ما اظن ان تبيد هذه ابدا وما
اظن الساعه
قائمه ويكفر
بالساعه يكفر بزوال هذا الشيء هذا شيء
خالد يعظم الدنيا تعظيم غير شكل ثم على
فوق هذا الكفر كله ماذا يقول يقول ولان
رجعت ولان رددت الى ربي
لاجدن خيرا منها
منقلبه يعني على فوق الكفر يقول لكن
جدلا لو في اخره
جدلا فاذا كان هيك ربنا اعطاني في الدنيا
شو رايك في الاخره استدل بالدنيا على
الاخره يستدل بافعال الله على اقواله هذا
هو سبيل
الهالكين انطعم من لو يشاء الله
اطعمه يستدل الله يامرهم بالانفاق هم
يقولون لو كان الله يريد ان نطعم فلانا
لاطعمه هو سبحانه هيك يقولون فهم يقولون
انطعم من لو يشاء الله
اطعمه اصل هذا الداء الاستدلال بافعال
الله على ماذا على اقوال الله هذا هو سبيل
الهلاك تماما لان الله لا يسال عما
يفعل من الذي يسال وهم يسالون نحن نسال
لذلك الله يامر شرعا ويفعل قدرا وهو لا
يسال عما يفعل ونحن نسال عما
امرنا نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
‏yer
even the fth
and سه
الر
قران الله سبحانه
وتعالى وان تعجب
[Silence]
‏fin number number الله سحانه
وتالى
‏strange that
strange another thing that is
am is that in the
earth there are pch
earth
that
‏fr even place watered by the water in
theate under the set of
circumstances the
fruits are very
different if that is am even
more الله سبحانه وتالى
‏resurrecting the dead even
more he سبحانه
وتعالى
evening
isat
‏if we
are rendered as
dust you saying that we will be
reassembled brought back to life after
this this is of
resp to the propet صل الله عليه وسلم
as teaches them about the day of
judgment the day of
resurrection that
‏res الله سبحه
وت the human being reassemble him bring
him back to
life a physic way and he will judge the
people and from their
their will parad will h will re
will
‏they view this is being something that
is impossible they can't believe that
this would
happen
inter they believe that الله سبحانه
وتالى creates anding for life from
death propet محد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
id
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله
life
res
‏and
very that a person would believe in
something الله سبحانه وتعالى creates the
human being creates the creation from
nothing
‏creating from
الله
that recreating
from
isly accord our accord to our physical
exp
easier الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه
وتعالى the creator the one who brings
for life from death from nothingness
recreating according to our
andas
more ‏capable bringing
for life from nothing or bringing
creating from
nothing there for is logical to
believe that they should be able to
recreate but they don't and that's part
of being a human being human being no
matter how clever
‏no matter how
clever no matter how clever how
intelligent how smart how much how
enlightened the human being will always
be pled with
contradiction human being must himself
is one hks being human being only
doct سحانه
وعالى سبحانه
وتعالى
usate قران
not and come to the
conclusion from other الله they would
find much contradiction
in any matter was
even صل عليه
وسل
الله human
always
even you could for schar a great schar
you find he has one opinion here and a
few pes
hect
‏sch
human this issue contradicting himself
these people that
believe الله سبحانه
وتالى
res life he
giv am
الله سبحانه وتالى
resp belief and he says those are the
people who disbelieve in their lord
truly and those are the individuals who
have yokes around
their yokes meaning a y
is basically a shle for the ne like
sh ‏for the is for the ne
now what does this me that these
individuals have yokes in their ne
around
their in the dun they have in this life
they have proverbial yokes around their
ne meaning that they have chosen
disbelief they cann see p
it
‏but in the here physical
yokes will be around
their he says and those individuals they
are the people the dwellers the
companions of the fire any
inion of the
fire
orell of the is
forever
even
‏may may
fored a of the
hellion of the fire that is tery
قران forever
etern فيها
خ
ان شاء الله الله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
[Silence]
اجمعين